[Musique]
depuis 9h20 de ce matin les femmes
travaillent gratuitement selon eurostat
l'écart de rémunération entre les femmes
et les hommes est en moyenne de 16 5% en
2021 un pourcentage en hausse constante
depuis 2018 l'année dernière la date
butoir était fixée à 16h16 le 4 novembre
pourriture
[Musique]
les conséquences économiques directes de
la pandémie sur les salaires ont elles
aussi été démontrée par une enquête
menée en juillet 2020 par l'ined 41% des
femmes de moins de 65 ans déclarent que
leurs revenus ont diminué depuis le
début du confinement sur sa formidable
que la parole soit libéré que les femmes
dénoncent et heureusement et on les
soutient et que certains hommes aussi
dénoncent des choses mais moi j'avoue
qu'en même temps j'ai du mal à dire à
quelqu'un comme j'ai dit dans cette
vidéo qui
vous êtes très belle vous avez un joli
décolleté et tu te prend une baffe dans
la gueule oui mais vous êtes très belle
ça pourrait suffire aujourd'hui mais
tentant de nous castrés là je trouve oui
mais attention quand même
quelle lettre manque à cette spécialité
lyonnaise souvent associé au carnaval
spécialités lyonnaises cédric le r non
laetitia avec le r vous vouliez faire
quoi comme on mène on vous avait dit
quoi laetitia logis le g ouais c'est une
bulle parce qu'alors avec le r il ya
bien qu'il vient mais je suis pas sûr
qu'on en mange beaucoup à lyon est-ce
moi qui
[Musique]
suis pas
je ne peux
l'étude du jour avec les mois éviter
quand on tente de draguer sur un site de
rencontres salut salut à pauline sales
us à cinq petites lettres qu'il faut
absolument bannir de votre vocabulaire
si vous passez des heures faire un gars
a essayé de pécho bah oui sur une appli
de rencontres étude réalisée par le
cabinet michel bart dont charles vous
même on dit encore que je veux mon temps
à l'est pas
à l'époque il fallait pécho
je peux plus écrire les peines que le
fémina aux mappeurs titao qui est michel
il est conseillé je cite d'utiliser des
introductions plus personnel et hâtive
ou épicés en fait l'idéal serait
[Rires]
je travaille très attentifs l'idéal en
fait c'est poser une question précise en
rapport avec le profil ou les photos de
la célibataire convoité je vois que tu
as été dans tel pays je vois que tu as
telle passion on y ajoute un ou deux
compliments ça fait toujours plaisir
madame morano déportés n'a pas brillé
d'abord c'est une femme sympathique
gilles contraire non mais c'est pas non
c'est une femme sympathique mais je dis
c'est une femme c'est une femme
authentique donc ça c'est intéressant pn
femmes cas du coffre de la voix de
l'intelligence un physique et un petit
chemisier léger compte avec ses hauts
talons c'est julien viale et grâce
évidemment qui nous rejoindre et ds wii
oblige non la voie alors voilà comme ça
ça s'appelle la fesse la voile on lui
fait la fesse pour pouvoir voir les
bateaux qui sont devant
regarde comme elle roule des teams aînés
donc ça c'est un roman de fès voilà
voilà
pour trop parce qu'après on perd de la
puissance dans le web il faut trouver le
juste milieu
ah ben voilà on va le spectacle et moi
j'étais chez laurent ruquier samedi soir
et c'est vrai que tout bon tu as dit que
tu étais magnifique les gens m'ont dit
qu'ils m'avaient pas reconnu ouais c'est
énorme et si on parlera lyonnais quand
même ça va entre connaît mais c'est vrai
que tu es tu es très très beau et a
directement assumé tu as dis ouais j'ai
pu j'ai eu recours à la chirurgie
esthétique en a même rigolé sur twitter
sans aucun tabou j'ai fait des implants
et les poches sous les yeux il y a deux
ans et les gens le découvrent maintenant
pour le blanchiment de la nuit chaude
vous tient au courant
la l'a fait c'est bien monté très
remonté un peu trop à mon goût mais bon
vous n'aimez pas les faits sont remontés
vous si la face est trop de ces cas pas
beaucoup de vent
alors ça ça c'est une phrase culte ce
que peut la répéter qu'il a fait c'est
trop haute y à passer devant
voilà comme un trou noir au milieu de
l'océan pacifique
en partageant cette image tirée de
google maps un internaute a suscité bon
nombre de théories sur les réseaux
sociaux allant de l'ovni écrasé au
cratère jusqu'au fameux triangle des
bermudes la réalité est beaucoup plus
terre à terre il s'agit probablement
d'un bug dans l'image satellite de l'île
de bau stock inhabitée et désormais
renouer on savait que michael jackson
elvis presley et le rappeur tupac vivait
sur une île selon les compos ti
désormais d'autres pensent que le fils
de john fitzgerald kennedy n'est pas
mort des adeptes de la mouvance
complotistes cannon se sont réunis hier
à dallas au texas à l'endroit exact où
l'ancien président américain a été
assassiné en 1963 ce n'est pas une
blague c'est vraiment sérieux ils
étaient plusieurs centaines
après donc sur la ceinture j'ai un petit
interrupteur qui vous permet de mettre
le mécanisme en route
et donc de produire la vapeur voilà
dans les conversations sont un petit peu
inédite et inattendue ça produit son
effet
[Applaudissements]
alors ces coupes énormes pour vous et
tous nos téléspectateurs john junior
n'est jamais venu l'une des théories
diffusé par la nébuleuse qui l'amène
affirmait que le fils de jfk et jeff
keay allait réapparaître pour annoncer
le retour de donald trump à la
présidence à des états unis et le
réinstaller à la maison blanche je la
trouvais légitime pour donner son avis
il ya deux sujets m il vous a vu cette
phrase absolue et vous êtes seul match
prise en otage je suis obligé de dire la
même chose que nadine morano alors je
vous présente le diable mais buvable il
est devant
c'est la fête
tout poulet trop cramé les zones trop
groupe a s'est massé j'ai à présent tu
as mis un peu de ketchup et un peu trucs
dedans pour faire une soupe j'ai mangé
j'essayais de gens nés des roland c'est
la journée de la gentillesse
aujourd'hui vous le savez non je trouve
que je suis je suis finalement les jours
je suis très gentil nadine c'était
vraiment bien ce que vous avez dit
c'était c'était c'était intéressant et
intelligent sa journée de la gentillesse
ça c'est récurrent
et limite on envie de vomir c'est mon
corps qui me le dire
non c'était franchement dégueulasse
d'une suite dé toilettes de space x va
obliger les astronautes à utiliser des
sous-vêtements de secours fait le nom
scientifique pour les couches tena des
mois qui se la raconte dans l'espace
avec leurs photos leurs tenues
futuristes et pourtant ils ont les mêmes
problèmes que sur terre rêvée de tôle
est visiblement l'équipage communiquent
très mal puisque dans le même temps
hasard du calendrier nous apprenons qu'à
bord de l iss les astronautes ont
préparé des tacos avec les piments
cultivés à bord de la station